just moments
after andre hill walked out of a garage
at a house where he was a guest
he was shot by police put your
hands out to the side hands out to the
side now
roll to your stomach now body cam
footage from officers in columbus ohio
appears to show andre hill an unarmed
black man
still alive as he lay wounded on the
ground
for more than five minutes officers left
him lying there without giving
any first aid mr hill was wearing a
black lives matter t-shirt under his
sweater
calling for justice for george floyd
[Music]
it then took between 5 and 13 minutes
before
anyone attempted to save andre hill's
life
according to his family's lawyer
everybody turn your cameras on camera's
on for the residents
anybody doing anything for them sir we
contact
medics
get some gloves you got gloves up yes
sir start pumping his chest
it was too late for the 47 year old who
became yet another unarmed black man
to die in an encounter with law
enforcement in america
where is the humanity for andre hill
where is the humanity
this columbus citizen
police officers were responding to a
non-emergency call from a neighbor
over a noise complaint when they
encountered mr hill
the white officer who fired the shots
adam coy
has now been sacked another officer
who was with him that night told an
internal police interview
she didn't feel andre hill posed a
danger did you observe any threats from
the subject
no were any verbal warnings given by
officer coy
no we had the expectation that he was
going to come out and talk to us
the conduct of all police staff who were
there on the 22nd of december is now
being investigated
andre hill should be alive today a
columbus police officer
is responsible for his death i can't
defend it
i can't make it right but i will do what
is in my power
andre hill's daughter is haunted
imagining her father
in his final moments i got to memorize
my dad on the floor for the rest of my
life and how nobody helped him how
there's 22 officers on the scene with
body footage and not
one of them helped my dad the family
says they won't stop
until they have justice for andre hill
sally lockwood sky news new york